الناقه الحسين ورجوه الموكب الاحمر وتواضع
الاميرتين ايمان وسلمى اليكم الابرز في
زفاف الملكي الاردني
[موسيقى]
بزيه العسكري الانيق بابتسامته ووسامته
وبجمال وجهها وهدوء ملامحها ورقي اطلالتها
وتاجها الذي يحمل اسمها لفت ولي عهد
الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
وعروسه الامير نجوى الحسين انظار
المتابعين في العالم العربي لمراسم زفاف
الملكي الذي شهدته العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
في الاول من حزيران يونيو 2023 تاريخ
سيبقى في ذاكره الاردنيين وربما العرب
عنوانا للبساطه والاناقه الملكيه والعادات
الاصيله وقف العاهل الاردني الملك عبد
الله الثاني والملكه رانيا العبد الله
لاستقبال ضيوف الزفاف الملكي عند بوابه
قصر زهران الذي شهد زفافهما قبل ثلاثين
عاما ووصل ولي العهد الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني بزيه العسكري المستوحى تصميمه
من زي والده في زفافه لترصد عدسه الكاميرا
نظره العريس بعينين يملاهما الحب الى
عروسه التي رافقها ش الامير هاشم وحرصت
شقيقتا الاميرتان ايمان وسلمى على ضبط
وترتيب فستان العروس الامر الذي اصبح
حديثا متابعين على منصات التواصل
لحظات عقد القران ونظرات العهد الاردني
لابنه ولي العهد ووالد العروس لابنته تلك
اللحظات التي تابعها العالم عبر شاشات
التلفزه قبل ان يتم تبديل خواتم الزواج
ويقبل الامير عروسه رجوى التي اصبحت اميره
رسميه الزغاريد التي صدح صوتها في ارجاء
قصر زهران وقبله ولي العهد ليد والدته
الملكه رانيا العبد الله التي كانت ترمقه
كام طوال الوقت بنظرات ستبقى في ذاكره
طويلا التقاليد الملكيه الاردنيه حضرت
بكامل ابهتها في الموكب الاحمر الذي جعل
بولي العهد وعروسه شوارع العاصمه الاردنيه
من قصر زهران الى قصر الحسينيه وسط حفاوه
الماره ابتهاجا بزفاف الملكي وعلى مقربه
من بوابه القصر استقبل الخيال العريس
وعروسه باستعراض مهيب وتلا مرورهما بين
سيوف المعقوده زفه اردنيه سعوديه بصوت
فنان العرب السعودي محمد عبده و الفنان
الاردني عمر العبد الله الذي اختتم مراسم
زفاف في قصر الحسينيه
[موسيقى]
وذلك قبل ان يشهد القصر استقبال الملك عبد
الله والملكه رانيا والامير الحسين وعروسه
الاميره رجوى وكبار الشخصيات العالميه
والعربيه التي حضرت الزفاف على ماذوبه
عشاء
[موسيقى]
مراسم ملكيه ضجت بها منصات التواصل مما
واكب الحدث الاردنيه السعيد سبقها
احتفالات استحضرت تقاليد الاردن كحمام
العريس الذي اقامه شقيق العهد الاردني
الامير فيصل لابن اخيه ومادبه العشاء التي
اقامها ملك الاردن في مضارب بني هاشم
لوجوه العشائر الاردنيه والسيف الذي اهداه
لابنه ولي العهد بمناسبه زفافه سيف هاشمي
هو نسخه من سيف جده المؤسس الملك عبد الله
الاول اراده ان يكون وصيه ورمزا للعدل
والدفاع عن الوطن ولا تزال الاحتفالات
مستمره بزفاف الملكي في الاردن الذي سبقه
مشاركه نجوم العرب للاردنيين فرحهم
بالحسين ويليه سلسله من الاحتفالات على
امتداد المملكه كانت الحدث الابرز لهذا
الاسبوع